Tasha: 还有一个手套能拿给我一下吗
Tasha: Can someone hand me another glove?
Lucia: 这个吗
Lucia: This one?
其他人：啊行了吗
Others: Is it okay now?
Lucia: 哎这好像不是手套
Lucia: Oh, this doesn't seem like a glove.
Alice: 你小心点啊
Alice: Be careful!
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry
Jake: 小心十分小心
Jake: Be very careful.
Lucia: 是那个厚的是吧
Lucia: Is it the thick one?
Jake: 齐的是吧
Jake: Is it the right one?
Tasha: 算了算了
Tasha: Forget it, forget it.
Lucia: 找到了
Lucia: Found it.
Jake: 然后我们这边还有多久
Jake: So, how much time do we have left here?
Jake: 大概
Jake: Roughly.
Jake: 大概大概还有几分钟呀
Jake: Roughly, how many minutes left?
Tasha: 五分钟五分钟
Tasha: Five minutes, five minutes.
Jake:五分钟好
Jake: Five minutes, okay.
Jake: 然后上面我直接开了就好
Jake: Then I can just open it from the top?
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Yes.
Jake: 嗯对
Jake: Yes, right.
Jake: 然后五分钟我
Jake: And then in five minutes I...
Jake: 就这基本放视频吧
Jake: Can basically play the video.
Alice: 要不我拿手套吧
Alice: How about I get the gloves?
Tasha: 能不能直接这样扣过来可以
Tasha: Can we just flip it over like this?
Tasha: 能不能直接这样扣过来
Alice:可以
Lucia: 底下的那个盘子还是要用这个抓吧
Lucia: Should we use this to grab the tray below?
Alice: 是
Alice: Yes.
Lucia: 你给我戴上
Lucia: Put it on me.
Alice:你扣上吧
Alice: Fasten it.
Tasha: 别太用力
Tasha: Don’t use too much force.
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh no.
其他人：这个也可以拿了吗哎4号是吗
Others: Can we take this now? Is it number 4?
Alice: 有点歪感觉
Alice: It’s a bit crooked.
Alice:有点变形
Alice: It's a bit deformed.
Alice:小心烫
Alice: Be careful, it's hot.
Alice: 没关系
Alice: It's okay.
Alice:没关系
Alice:弄弄弄粉吧
Alice: Let's apply some powder.
Lucia: 我再撕张纸
Lucia: I'll tear another piece of paper.
Lucia: 然后把它放到那
Lucia: And then place it there.
Alice: 杨老板下来了吗
Alice: Has Jake come down yet?
Alice: 这样吧上面进行到什么环节了
Alice: So, what's the next step?
其他人：也没什么事儿
Others: Nothing much.
Alice: 问答
Alice: Q&A.
Alice: 一个弄五个
Alice: Make five of them.
Alice: 五个放不下
Alice: Five won't fit.
Alice: 最多四个
Alice: Four at most.
Lucia: 三四个的样子三个把那就
Lucia: Maybe three or four. Let's do three then.
Alice: 抹茶可以少两个
Alice: We can reduce two matcha ones.
Alice: 因为那个抹茶不是重了
Alice: Because the matcha ones aren't that heavy.
Alice:蛋挞太热了
Alice:容易化
Alice: It melts easily.
Tasha: 应该早点做蛋挞
Tasha: We should've made the egg tarts earlier.
Alice:没事儿 那个鸡蛋 来的太晚了
Alice: It's fine. The eggs came too late.
Tasha:  我们如果把今天把蛋挞放冰箱过一会再
Tasha: If we put the egg tarts in the fridge for a while...
Tasha: 下来行不行
Tasha: Will that work?
Alice: 放明早可能有点潮不过反正也没有那么脆
Alice: If we leave them until tomorrow morning, they might get a bit soggy, but they won't be that crispy anyway.
Alice: 磕磕脑袋这个
Alice: Bump your head on this.
Alice: 没关系
Alice: It's okay.
Alice: 有的人喜欢吃
Alice: Some people like to eat this.
Lucia: 对不起
Lucia: Sorry.
Lucia: 没事
Lucia: It's okay.
Alice: 就是这个就是这个
Alice: Just this one, just this one.
Lucia: 这个是这个吗
Lucia: Is this the one?
Alice:对
其他人：装到盘里吧把这六个把这这六个
Others: Put them on the plate, these six, these six.
Alice: 我擦砸下这个
其他人：等会等会再砸
Others: Wait, wait, do it later.
其他人：有点小翻车
Others: There's a bit of a mishap.
Alice:无妨
Alice: It's alright.
Alice: 什么视频
Alice: What video?
Alice: 啊我也没看过
Alice: Oh, I haven't seen it either.
其他人：呆会儿给你们单独放一下
Others: We'll show it to you separately later.
其他人：就六个这一圈
Others: Just these six, around here.
Alice: 撒豆
Alice: Sprinkle some beans.
其他人：这个是
Others: This one is...
其他人：有没有翻车的我可试吃一下
Others: Any mishaps? Let me taste one.
Alice: 这个
Alice: This one.
Alice: 你可以沾点这上面的粉
Alice: You can dip it in the powder here.
其他人：这个啊
Others: This one?
Alice: 这两个都是你可沾点
Alice: Both of these, you can dip a bit.
其他人：往前放一点
Others: Move it forward a bit.
Lucia: 我的
Lucia: Mine.
Lucia: 没事
Lucia: It's okay.
Lucia: 其实昨天晚上就得化
Lucia: Actually, it should've been done last night.
Lucia: 然后我们就放冰箱了
Lucia: Then we put it in the fridge.
Lucia: 然后现在滑人认领它
Lucia: And now someone needs to claim it.
Lucia: 妈呀这画的好夸张啊
Lucia: Wow, this is so exaggerated.
Alice:这个得撒粉呢
Alice: We need to sprinkle some powder on it.
Lucia: 刚这个刚这个撕开的行不行
Lucia: Can we use the one we just tore open?
Alice: 还有一个你把那个吃了吧
Alice: There's another one, you can eat that one.
其他人：恩不要了一个够了
Others: No, we don't need more, one is enough.
Lucia: 比较快一些
Lucia: It’s faster this way.
Alice:这这这反正 就这样吧
Alice: This, this, anyway, let's leave it like this.
Lucia:  好像不够大是吗
Lucia: It seems like it’s not big enough, right?
其他人：不是要搁这里搁锡纸上吗
Others: Aren't we supposed to put it here on the foil?
Alice: 不是还得撒粉
Alice: We still need to sprinkle the powder.
其他人：哎这做几个蛋挞也可以
Others: Oh, we can make a few egg tarts too.
Alice: 放点蓝莓吗还是草莓
Alice: Should we add some blueberries or strawberries?
Tasha: 啊这个就不放
Tasha: Ah, let's not add anything.
Tasha: 放盘拖盘地
Tasha: Just put it on the tray.
其他人：这四个啊
Others: These four, huh?
Alice: 这四个抹茶
Alice: These four are matcha.
其他人：要不都放这一个拖盘
Others: Why not put them all on this one tray?
Alice:看能放下不
Alice: Let's see if they fit.
Lucia: 我用一只手抓不起来
Lucia: I can't pick it up with one hand.
Lucia: 但我另一只手一定要拿
Lucia: But I have to hold it with my other hand.
其他人：需要用个铲子吗
Others: Do you need a spatula?
Alice: 那那个是弄提拉米苏的可能还没刷呢
Alice: 四个
Alice: Four.
Alice: 有点挤
Alice: It's a bit cramped.
Tasha: 为什么这样子放三个三个放就行
Tasha: Why don't we just put three on each tray?
Alice: 没盆了
Alice: There's no more trays.
Tasha: 那还有别的盘吗
Tasha: Are there any other trays?
其他人：哦这这几个都放这一盘
Others: Oh, let’s put all of these on this tray.
Tasha: 啊不要
Tasha: Ah, no.
Alice: 还有盘吗
Alice: Are there any more trays?
Lucia: 那样不好看
Lucia: It won't look good that way.
Lucia: 好好看 拿起来 还有盘吗
Lucia: Looks good, pick it up. Are there any more trays?
Alice: 还有盘吗
Alice: Are there any more trays?
Lucia: 我们还有别的那种吗
Lucia: Do we have any other types?
Lucia: 回味一下
Lucia: Let's savor it.
Lucia: 那种托盘那个架子呢
Lucia: Where's that tray stand?
Lucia: 在这
Lucia: It's here.
Alice: 那个架子已经
Alice: That stand is already...
Lucia: 那个架子是不是刚刚放着东西呢
Lucia: Wasn't that stand just holding something?
Alice: 抹茶粉在这
Alice: The matcha powder is here.
Alice: 可以给我拽点纸么
Alice: Can you grab me some paper?
Alice: 好好好谢谢
Alice: Okay, okay, thanks.
Alice: 无妨
Alice: No problem.
其他人：草莓还用再切吗
Others: Do we need to cut more strawberries?
Alice: 不用吃吧
Alice: No, just eat them.
其他人：不是要放回去吗
Others: Aren't we going to put them back?
其他人：你要吃
Others: Do you want to eat them?
Lucia: 对谢谢
Lucia: Yes, thank you.
其他人：把这个叶给它摘了  这个都洗了吗
Others: Take off the leaves. Have they all been washed?
Alice: 不不不用摘叶子
Alice: No, no, don't take off the leaves.
Alice:正着放倒着放还是这样放
Alice: Should we place them upright or upside down?
其他人：咱可以先放上面然后再
Others: We can put them on top first and then...
其他人：你两吃吧
Others: You two go ahead and eat.
其他人：要不先放上去再再都行
Others: Or we can put them on top first, either way.
Lucia: 哇已经开始那个什么了吗
Lucia: Wow, did it already start?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 那我上去整理一下
Lucia: I'll go up and tidy up.
其他人：油纸
Others: Parchment paper.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Tasha: 要我帮你拿些东西
Tasha: Do you need me to get something for you?
Lucia: 没事没事
Lucia: No, it's fine.
其他人：让你给撕坏了
Others: You tore it.
Lucia: 稍等一下啊
Lucia: Hold on a sec.
其他人：放了放了
Others: It's placed, it's placed.
其他人：一层两个
Others: Two per layer.
Tasha: 这么立桌子上
Tasha: Stand it on the table like this.
其他人：这个别这个少
Others: Not too many of these.
Lucia: 整理一下
Lucia: Let's tidy up.
其他人：啊我等会
Others: Ah, wait a minute.
Alice:走吧
Alice: Let's go.
Alice: 辛着坏了吧
Alice: Did it break?
Alice:走吧
Alice: Let's go.
Alice:怎么会没网呢
Alice: How come there's no signal?
Alice: 啊坐哪
Alice: Ah, where should we sit?
Jake:坐找地方坐
Jake: Find a place to sit.
Alice: 我们能坐这吗
Alice: Can we sit here?
Jake:当然可以
Jake: Of course.
Alice: 好的
Alice: Okay.
Alice: 能坐这吗
Alice: Can we sit here?
Alice: 就这
Alice: Here?
Alice: 太靠前了
Alice: It's too close to the front.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure:  给大家看一遍Tasha的部分
Shure: Let’s show everyone Tasha's part.
Alice: 哎哟
Alice: Oops.
Alice: 坐吗
Alice: Sit?
Shure:  又介绍我
Shure: Introducing me again.
Shure:  修 修的下面
Shure: Shure, below Shure.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure:  啊我们的Tasha
Shure: Ah, our Tasha.
Shure:  也就是我们今天所有甜点的
Shure: She’s the one who made all our desserts today.
Shure:  甜点的厨师
Shure: She’s our dessert chef.
Shure:  就是我们的首席甜点师
Shure: She’s our head pastry chef.
Shure: 然后刚刚在 歌词里介绍的人对
Shure: And the person mentioned in the lyrics earlier.
Jake:对在歌词里介绍 现在介绍的是爱丽丝
Jake: Yes, mentioned in the lyrics. Now we’re introducing Alice.
Shure:  Alice跑了
Shure: Alice ran away.
Shure:  Alice梦游仙境去了啊
Shure: Alice went to Wonderland.
Alice: 啊在这儿呢
Alice: Oh, I'm here.
Shure:  在这呢OK
Shure: Here you are, okay.
Shure: 行介绍完了
Shure: Alright, introduction done.
Jake:行介绍完了 那我们来
Jake: Alright, introduction done. Now let's...
Shure:  还回到QA吧
Shure: Get back to QA.
Jake:来进行QA
Jake: Do the QA.
Jake:稍有叹息
Jake: A little sigh.
Jake:那我们
Jake: So we...
Jake:有一个 有一个   回签问题时间
Jake: Have a question and answer session.
Jake:如果答对抢答的环节答对了就会拿到1个EGO币
Jake: If you answer the quiz correctly, you will get one EGO coin.
Jake:这个EGO币 可以用来换取
Jake: This EGO coin can be exchanged for...
Alice: 找人吗
Alice: A person?
Jake:地未来还有 准备
Jake: In the future, we have prepared...
Alice: 还是去后边
Alice: Or go to the back?
Jake:现在EGO币每一个的价格是 现在多少钱
Jake: Now each EGO coin is worth... How much?
Shure:  3块钱吧
Shure: About 3 yuan.
Jake:3块人民币
Jake: 3 RMB.
Shure: 差不多
Shure: About that.
Jake:现在每个EGO币3块钱人民币
Jake: Now each EGO coin is 3 RMB.
Jake:然后 明天 我们再看看完事
Jake: Then, let's check it out again tomorrow.
Jake:那我们第5题
Jake: Now for our fifth question.
Jake:世界地球日是哪一天
Jake: When is Earth Day?
Shure:  抢举手吗
Shure: Do we raise our hands?
Shure:  白衣少年
Shure: The guy in white.
Shure:  他选择了2B
Shure: He chose 2B.
Shure:  2B
Shure: 2B.
Shure:  杨老板正确吗
Shure: Jake, is that correct?
Shure:  你觉得挺对的
Shure: Do you think it's right?
Shure:  那你觉得这题应该值几个ego币
Shure: How many ego coins do you think this question is worth?
Jake: 我觉得可能不太值
Jake: I think it's not worth much.
Jake:因为它是第0题
Jake: Because it's the zeroth question.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
其他人：0不就是第一开始吗
Others: Isn't zero the first one?
Jake:这是一个热身让大家知道怎么举手
Jake: It's a warm-up to show everyone how to raise their hands.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure:  但是我觉得
Shure: But I think...
Shure:  第一个回答问题的同学勇气可嘉
Shure: The first student to answer deserves some credit for bravery.
Shure:  我们应该发出支持一下发出ego币
Shure: We should give out some ego coins to support that.
Jake:支持一下
Jake: Let's support that.
Shure:  我们的第一个ego币
Shure: Our first ego coin.
Jake:我们的第一个EGO币
Jake: Our first EGO coin.
Shure:  军事项链
Shure: Military chain.
Shure:  然后大家那个活动结束
Shure: After the event, you can find Xie Bin Zhu.
Shure:  可以找谢斌竹同学
Shure: To exchange it into your Mata Max wallet.
Shure:  兑换到自己的那个Mata Max的钱包里面
Shure:
Alice:谢谢
Alice: Thank you.
Shure:  然后下一题
Shure: Next question.
Shure:  首次庆祝世界地球日是哪一年
Shure: In which year was Earth Day first celebrated?
Shure:  a 1960年
Shure: a) 1960
Shure:  b 1970年
Shure: b) 1970
Shure:  c 1980年
Shure: c) 1980
Shure:  d 2024年
Shure: d) 2024
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:选B
Jake: Choose B.
Shure:  他选择二b
Shure: He chose 2B.
Shure:  还有哪位同学有不同意见呢
Shure: Does anyone have a different opinion?
Shure:  白毛同学放手
Shure: The guy with white hair, put your hand down.
其他人：二毛选b
Others: Ermao chose B.
其他人：今天勇气可佳
Others: Today's bravery is commendable.
Shure:  他选择的这个日子
Shure: The date he chose
Shure:  就是那种班级倒数第一同学看一眼
Shure: It's like the kind of answer the last student in the class would pick
Shure:  题都不会选的答案
Shure: The kind where they can't even choose the right question
Shure:  还有还有同学吗
Shure: Are there any other students?
其他人：我选C
Others: I'll choose C
Shure:  你选c是吧
Shure: You're choosing C, right?
Alice: 刘婷
Alice: Liu Ting
Alice: 举手
Alice: Raise your hand
其他人：我选a
Others: I'll choose A
Shure:  看来我们的这个选项非常的焦灼大家
Shure: It seems our options are very competitive, everyone
Shure:  大家难分伯仲
Shure: Everyone is evenly matched
Shure:  只能说那我们公布一下正确答案
Shure: Let's just announce the correct answer
其他人：我查一下
Others: Let me check
Jake:选B1970年
Jake: Choose B, 1970
Alice: 啊
Alice: Ah
Jake:确定
Jake: Confirmed
Shure:  又是这位又是白衣少年
Shure: It's this guy again, the guy in white again
Jake:好请
Jake: Alright, please
Jake:好我们来到了
Jake: Okay, we have come to
其他人：每次B都是那迷惑性最强的那个
Others: Every time B is the most confusing one
其他人：是这样的
Others: That's true
Shure:  第二题谁是世界地球日的创始人
Shure: Second question, who is the founder of Earth Day?
Shure:  A艾尔伯特爱因斯坦
Shure: A. Albert Einstein
其他人：我抢答 A
Others: I'll answer A
Shure:  B盖盖
Shure: B. Gaye
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure:  盖诺特尼德尼尔森
Shure: Gaylord Nelson
Shure:  C修硕
Shure: C. Shure
Alice:哎哟
Alice: Oh my
Shure:  D尚柯欣
Shure: D. John Connors
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure:  我我感觉相机小哥你最你最快这次
Shure: I feel like the camera guy, you're the fastest this time
其他人：那要不我看大家 都喜欢 选B就选B吧
Others: Well, if everyone likes to choose B, let's choose B then
Shure:  他选择了B
Shure: He chose B
Shure:  还有不同答案吗
Shure: Any different answers?
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
其他人：所以我选C
Others: So I'll choose C
其他人：好选
Others: Good choice
Shure:  那个白白衣少年
Shure: The guy in white
Shure:  啊好的好的
Shure: Ah, alright, alright
Shure:  那我们
Shure: So we...
Shure:  想必大家已经知道
Shure: I guess everyone already knows...
Shure:  这个正确答案是什么了吧
Shure: what the correct answer is, right?
Shure:  选择
Shure: Choose...
Alice: D
Shure:   选择B其实
Shure: Actually, choosing B...
Alice: D
Shure:  给大家科普一下
Shure: Let me give you some info...
Shure:  这个盖洛德尼尔森
Shure: about this Gaylord Nelson...
Shure:  大家可能不知道他是谁吧
Shure: You guys might not know who he is, right?
Shure:  他是这个世界地球日的创始人
Shure: He is the founder of Earth Day.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure:  好的那个
Shure: Alright, so...
Shure:  这这个题我觉得难度系数非常的大
Shure: I think this question is extremely difficult...
Shure:  需要奖励两个币子来同学
Shure: and deserves two coins for the students.
Shure:  但鉴于刚刚那个
Shure: But considering the student who...
Shure:  选择D选项的同学
Shure: chose option D...
Shure:  勇气非常可嘉
Shure: showed great courage...
Shure:  我觉得也应该奖励一枚
Shure: I think they deserve a coin too.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Alice: 笑死了
Alice: So funny.
Shure:  选C选项那个就是
Shure: Option C, that one is...
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure:  就是大葱
Shure: It's green onions.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure:  后面同学把嘴闭上
Shure: Students in the back, close your mouths.
Jake:还有电吗
Jake: Is there any power left?
Shure:  啊第三个
Shure: Ah, the third one...
其他人： 咱仨已经讨论过为什么没有电
Others: We three have already discussed why there's no power.
Shure: 哪个重要的日子是在第一个世界地球日后成立的
Shure: Which important day was established after the first Earth Day?
Shure:  A国家公园管理局
Shure: A. National Park Service
Shure:  B美国农业局
Shure: B. U.S. Department of Agriculture
Shure:  C美国环境保护局
Shure: C. Environmental Protection Agency
Shure:  D美国鱼类和野生动物服务局
Shure: D. U.S. Fish and Wildlife Service
其他人：C感觉是
Others: C seems right.
Shure:  选C还有不同答案吗
Shure: Choose C. Any different answers?
Shure:  选最长是吗
Shure: Choose the longest one, right?
Shure:  OK选D
Shure: Okay, choose D.
Shure:  还有其他答案吗
Shure: Any other answers?
Shure:  他选了B
Shure: He chose B.
Alice: 选A
Alice: Choose A.
Shure:  你你不要参加回答
Shure: Hey, you shouldn't be answering.
Alice: 我不在范围啊
Alice: I'm not in the scope, right?
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  要不这位同学你选一下
Shure: How about you choose, classmate?
Shure:  好公布一下正确答案吧
Shure: Alright, let's reveal the correct answer.
Shure:  杨老板
Shure: Jake?
Jake:美国环境保护局
Jake: The US Environmental Protection Agency.
Shure:  OK
Shure: OK.
Shure:  我觉得这题也值
Shure: I think this question is also worth it.
其他人：确定太难了
Others: Definitely too hard.
Shure:  两个币
Shure: Two tokens.
Alice: 很快你就可以赎走我了
Alice: Soon, you can redeem me.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
其他人：我俩合资
Others: We'll pool our resources.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure:  然后下面第四题
Shure: Now, the fourth question.
Shure:  大约有多少人参加的
Shure: About how many people attended?
Shure:  第一个世界地球日
Shure: in the first Earth Day?
Shure:  A 30万
Shure: A. 300,000
Shure:  B 200万
Shure: B. 2 million
Shure:  C 300人
Shure: C. 300
Shure:  D  2000万人
Shure: D. 20 million
Alice: 300人
Alice: 300
Shure:  这位同学
Shure: This student
Shure:  你一直默默无闻
Shure: You've been quiet
Shure:  你要不回答一下
Shure: How about you give it a shot?
Shure:  有人选C了
Shure: Someone chose C
Alice: 300人
Alice: 300
Shure:  你选什么啊
Shure: What's your choice?
Shure:  好的
Shure: Okay
其他人：我选第四个
Others: I choose the fourth one
Shure:  他选第四个
Shure: He chose the fourth one
Shure:  他们两个选了一个极端
Shure: They picked two extremes
Shure:  一个选了300人
Shure: One chose 300
Shure:  一个选了2000万人哈哈哈
Shure: One chose 20 million, hahaha
Shure:  还有不同答案吗
Shure: Any other answers?
Shure:  你看看这个头脑
Shure: Check out this brain.
Alice: 中庸之道
Alice: The middle way.
Shure:  中庸之道对
Shure: The Doctrine of the Mean, right.
Shure:  选择了30万还有吗
Shure: You chose 300,000, is there more?
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure:  我就知道
Shure: I knew it.
其他人：有没有总有人是 对的
Others: Is there always someone who is right?
Shure:  对
Shure: Right.
Shure:  公布答案
Shure: Announce the answer.
Shure:  杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Jake:2000万人
Jake: 20 million people.
Alice: 哇这么多人
Alice: Wow, so many people.
Shure:  没有想到吧
Shure: Didn't expect that, right?
Shure:  就是说明这个日子非常重要
Shure: This shows that this day is very important.
Shure:  第一次办就有这么多人参加
Shure: So many people participated the first time it was held.
Shure:  哪哪位同学选择2000万来着
Shure: Which student chose 20 million?
Shure:  白衣小哥
Shure: The guy in white.
Shure:  这个这个问题两个币
Shure: For this question, you get two tokens.
Jake:这个可以稍作科普
Jake: Let's do a bit of science popularization.
Jake:因为这个世界地球日
Jake: Because this is Earth Day.
Jake:它主要在高校之间
Jake: It's mainly among universities.
Jake:高校内进行
Jake: Held within universities.
Jake:然后高校的那帮人
Jake: And the people in universities.
其他人：都算进去了
Others: Are all included.
Jake:对然后搞了进去
Jake: Yes, they are all included.
Shure:  所以我们有2,000万人参加
Shure: So we have 20 million participants.
Shure:  出名的一个
Shure: It's a famous one.
Shure:  好的下一题
Shure: Alright, next question.
Alice: 甜品在哪不不不
Alice: Where's the dessert, no, no, no.
Shure:  今年的世界地球日的主题是什么
Shure: What's this year's Earth Day theme?
Shure:  A投资我们的星球
Shure: A. Invest in Our Planet.
Shure:  B动员地球
Shure: B. Mobilize the Earth.
Alice: 我不吃我就看它在哪儿
Alice: I'm not eating, just looking for it.
Shure:  C星球对抗塑料
Shure: C. Planet vs. Plastics.
Shure:  D 10亿绿色行动
Shure: D. Billion Acts of Green.
Shure:  请抢答
Shure: Please buzz in.
Tasha: 其他人：
Tasha: Others:
Shure:  选A是吗
Shure: You chose A, right?
Shure:  还有不同答案吗
Shure: Any different answers?
Shure:  来C
Shure: Come on, C.
其他人：4D
Others: 4D.
Shure:  4D你你们俩谁先他他他
Shure: 4D, who was first, him, him, him.
Shure:  他你确定
Shure: Are you sure about this?
Shure:  4D还是让给他
Shure: Should we let him have 4D?
其他人：我2B好了
Others: I'll take 2B then.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure:  好的
Shure: Okay.
Shure:  BDCA然后你是c是吧好的
Shure: BDCA and you're C, right? Okay.
Shure:  D
Shure: D.
Shure:  C
Shure: C.
Shure:  A
Shure: A.
Shure:  然后你是c是吧
Shure: And you're C, right?
Shure:  好的
Shure: Okay.
Shure:  c选项今年的主题叫做planet versus plastic
Shure: The theme for option C this year is called "Planet versus Plastic."
Shure:  就是星球对抗塑料
Shure: Which means "Planet against Plastic."
Shure:  是我们今年的世界地球日的主题
Shure: It's our Earth Day theme for this year.
Shure:  然后恭喜
Shure: And congratulations.
Shure:  相相机同学
Shure: To our classmate Xiang Xiang.
其他人：对其他这个主题都是安全的
Others: Yes, the rest of the theme is safe.
其他人：是有过的还是没有的啊好问
Others: Is this a new or old one? Good question.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Alice: 好问题
Alice: Good question.
其他人：这个选项是生造出来的还是
Others: Is this option made up or...
Shure:  不不不不
Shure: No, no, no.
Jake:这所有的题目都是
Jake: All these questions are...
Shure:  但是答案是保证的
Shure: But the answers are guaranteed.
Tasha: 这也告诉别人
Tasha: This also tells others.
Alice: 这是可以说的吗
Alice: Is this okay to say?
Shure:  啊没有没有
Shure: Ah, no, no.
Shure:  这个
Shure: This...
Shure:  其他确实是都没有
Shure: The rest really aren't.
Shure:  没有出现过的都是胡诌出来的
Shure: Those that haven't appeared are all made up.
Shure:  然后
Shure: And...
Shure:  这题三个币
Shure: This question is worth three coins.
Shure:  这怎么还有氛围组呢
Shure: Why is there a vibe group here too?
Shure:  下一题第7题
Shure: Next question, question 7.
Shure:  地球的南极冰
Shure: The Antarctic ice of the Earth...
Shure:  啊地球的南极冰盖
Shure: Ah, the Antarctic ice cap of the Earth...
Shure:  锁定了多少比百分比的淡水
Shure: How much percentage of freshwater is locked in it?
Shure:  A大约50%
Shure: A, about 50%.
Shure:  B大约70%
Shure: B, about 70%.
Shure:  C大约90%
Shure: C, about 90%.
Shure:  D大约30%
Shure: About 30% for D
Shure:  C
Shure: C
Shure:  2B
Shure: 2B
Jake:你好啊早上好
Jake: Hey, good morning
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay
Shure:  没事没有其他的选项
Shure: No worries, there are no other options
Shure:  公布答案90
Shure: The answer is 90
Jake:90
Jake: 90
Shure:  90%
Shure: 90%
Shure:  我们其实世界
Shure: Actually, our world
Shure:  呃就是地球上最大的淡水资源
Shure: Uh, the largest freshwater resource on Earth
Shure:  都是南极冰盖锁定的
Shure: Is locked in the Antarctic ice sheet
Shure:  对所以是90%
Shure: So it's 90%
Shure:  然后这题也三个币子吧
Shure: And this question should be worth three coins too
Alice: 提问冰盖跟奶盖什么意
Alice: Question, what's the relationship between ice sheets and milk caps
Alice: 什么关系
Alice: What's the connection
Shure:  好问题好问题
Shure: Good question, good question
Shure:  就是在我说说你听听
Shure: Let me tell you a story, listen up
Shure:  在想当初
Shure: A long time ago
Shure:  大约3500万年前
Shure: About 35 million years ago
Shure:  女娲补天的时候创造了一个双胞胎
Shure: When Nüwa was patching up the sky, she created a pair of twins
Shure:  一个叫冰盖一个叫奶盖
Shure: One was called Ice Sheet, the other Milk Cap
其他人：我有一个我有一个问题
Others: I have a question, I have a question
Shure:  对大概就是这么
Shure: Yeah, roughly like that
Lucia: 本来想坐那
Lucia: I was planning to sit there
Lucia: 但是坐那好像挡不住后面的嘉宾
Lucia: But it seems like it blocks the guests behind
其他人：就是因为我印象里他的淡水是72%
Others: Because I remember the freshwater is 72%
Lucia: 要不然还是坐这吧
Lucia: Maybe I'll just sit here
但是他的冰盖是90%其他人：
But the ice sheet is 90%, others:
Tasha: 你们团队中有哪些人是单身呀
Tasha: Who in your team is single?
其他人：但是这个提的问题是
Others: But the question is
Tasha: 我感觉没有几个单身
Tasha: I feel like not many are single
其他人：他的储存多少淡水
Others: How much freshwater it stores
其他人：而不是冰盖有多少水
Others: Not how much water the ice sheet has
Tasha: 你是单身
Tasha: Are you single?
其他人：我觉得你们可以搜 一下这个答案
Others: I think you guys can look up the answer
Tasha: 你也不是
Tasha: You aren't either
Tasha: 那有谁是单身
Tasha: Then who's single?
Shure:  不是他是就是占
Shure: No, it's about how much
Shure:  占了全球淡水的多少
Shure: How much of the world's freshwater it holds
其他人：但是你说的是淡水90%只是水
Others: But you said 90% of freshwater is just water.
Tasha: 你们4个不是单身
Tasha: You four are not single.
其他人：我觉得你可以看一下那个有没有
Others: I think you can check that out.
其他人：你再搜一下
Others: Search again.
Tasha: 他不是也有吗
Tasha: Doesn't he have it too?
其他人：你看你是不是淡水喝水
Others: Are you drinking freshwater?
Shure:  有人提出了challenge
Shure: Someone proposed a challenge.
Shure:  杨老板
Shure: Jake.
其他人：直播直播
Others: Live stream, live stream.
其他人： 搜索面积超过这个14后面6个0平方公里
Others: The search area exceeds 14 followed by six zeros square kilometers.
Tasha: 那就他就杨靖康
Tasha: Then it's him, Yang Jingkang.
Alice:6个0个十百千哦
Alice: Six zeros, ten, hundred, thousand...
Tasha: 是单
Tasha: Is single.
Alice:不用谢谢
Alice: No need, thanks.
其他人：是地球上所有淡的约70%
Others: About 70% of the Earth's freshwater.
Tasha: 他这么单
Tasha: He's so single.
Tasha: 他这么神秘
Tasha: He's so mysterious.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
其他人：我要退回去吗3个退回去
Others: Should I go back? Three go back.
Tasha: 大家都好
Tasha: Everyone's good.
Alice: 是水有70%陆地有30% 70%的水里有是90%的水才是
Alice: Water is 70%, land is 30%. Out of the 70% water, 90% is...
其他人：如果把那个谈字去年它就准了
Others: If you remove the word "talk," it's accurate.
Lucia: 大家好认真
Lucia: Everyone's so serious.
Lucia: 没想到
Lucia: Didn't expect that.
Tasha: 但长得痘痘有点多 为啥呀
Tasha: But why so many pimples?
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Alice:对因为有的水不是淡水
Alice: Yes, because some water isn't freshwater.
Shure:  那
Shure: Well.
Shure:  转移一下资产
Shure: Transfer some assets.
Jake:转移资产
Jake: Transfer assets.
其他人：我不确定哪 三个是原来的
Others: I'm not sure, which three were the originals?
Tasha: 没关系
Tasha: It's okay.
Shure:  然后那我们再奖励一枚币子给
Shure: And then we'll reward a coin to...
Shure:  查出正确答案的同学
Shure: The student who found the correct answer.
Shure:  非常的好
Shure: Very good.
Shure:  那么下一题
Shure: Next question.
Shure:  地球的南极
Shure: The South Pole of the Earth.
Shure:  他让我梅开二度的难堪
Shure: It made me awkward for the second time.
Alice: 不用了谢谢
Alice: No thanks.
Shure:  从太阳到地球
Shure: From the Sun to the Earth.
Shure:  阳光需要多长时间到达
Shure: How long does it take for sunlight to reach
Shure:  这个
Shure: Here?
Shure:  其实是我们好像高中那种经常算的
Shure: Actually, it's something we often calculated in high school.
Shure:  哎呦已经有两位同学举手了
Shure: Oh, two classmates have already raised their hands.
Shure:  8分19秒
Shure: 8 minutes and 19 seconds.
Shure:  哎呦其实你们两个同时举手
Shure: Wow, you two raised your hands at the same time.
Shure:  那你们还有其他答案吗
Shure: Do you have any other answers?
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure:  你选D
Shure: You chose D.
Shure:  你知道这个D
Shure: Do you know what this D
Shure:  意味着什么意思吗
Shure: Means?
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure:  这是我们的表
Shure: This is our clock.
Shure:  转了20圈才有一天会看到太阳
Shure: It takes 20 turns to see the sun in a day.
Alice: 确保一定有一个正确答案
Alice: Make sure there's a correct answer.
Alice: 为我们的顺利进行
Alice: For our smooth progress.
Shure:  这这位同学纠正了我的我的错误
Shure: This classmate corrected my mistake.
Shure:  是表转40圈
Shure: It's actually 40 turns.
Shure:  是20圈啊
Shure: Not 20 turns.
Shure:  对对对我疏忽了
Shure: Yes, yes, I made an oversight.
Shure:  正确答案就是A
Shure: The correct answer is A.
Shure:  是吧
Shure: Right?
Shure:  对是8分19秒
Shure: Yes, it's 8 minutes and 19 seconds.
Shure:  大家还记得那个怎么算的了吗
Shure: Do you still remember how to calculate that?
其他人：谁问你了
Others: Who asked you?
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure:  是是就其实就是这么简单
Shure: It's actually quite simple.
Shure:  对
Shure: Yeah.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
其他人：是这样的
Others: That's right.
其他人：所以如果真的是海鲜的话
Others: So if it really were seafood,
其他人：那那南京应该肯定不会占地球了
Others: Then Nanjing definitely wouldn't be on Earth.
其他人：但是40% 那起码太阳没了地球还
Others: But 40% at least, without the sun, the Earth still...
Shure:  来
Shure: Come on.
Lucia: 但问题太阳会持续发光
Lucia: But the problem is the sun will keep shining.
Lucia: 他又不是歘一下然后又熄灭
Lucia: It won't just go out suddenly.
Shure:  你们你们二位每人两个
Shure: You two each get two.
其他人：所以所以
Others: So, so...
其他人：另一方面感谢是
Others: On the other hand, thanks...
其他人：如果这个样子的话
Others: If it's like this...
其他人：太阳坏掉了的话
Others: If the sun breaks down
其他人：你还能
Others: can you still
Lucia: 再活20天
Lucia: live for another 20 days
其他人：哈哈哈也就说我先看到8分钟之前
Others: Hahaha, so you mean I saw it 8 minutes before
Lucia: 太阳冷却了
Lucia: The sun cools down
Tasha: 哇好有道理啊
Tasha: Wow, that makes so much sense
Lucia: 我们还能再活20天
Lucia: We can live for another 20 days
Alice: 哇哦
Alice: Wow
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure:  下一个问题
Shure: Next question
Shure:  陨石
Shure: Meteorites
Shure:  为什么每次都能精准的砸到陨石坑
Shure: Why do they always hit the craters so precisely?
Lucia:谁把这个问题加进去了
Lucia: Who added this question?
Shure:  这是一个开放型问题
Shure: This is an open-ended question
Shure:  根据你们的回答我思
Shure: Based on your answers, I will
Shure:  根据你们的回答我进行判断给你们发币
Shure: Based on your answers, I'll judge and give you points
Lucia: 好好好
Lucia: Okay, okay
Shure:  这个每人都来回答一下来
Shure: Everyone should answer this one
Shure:  反方辩手
Shure: Opposing debater
Shure:  那我们宣判反方一正方一变赢了
Shure: Then we declare one win for the opposing side and one for the affirmative side
Shure:  你跟靖康是一种
Shure: You and Jingkang are one
Shure:  你跟靖康是一种 好
Shure: You and Jingkang are one, okay
Shure:  你先思考然后
Shure: Think about it first and then
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure:  就你不知道他是胡诌的还是真的然后就开始
Shure: You don’t know if he’s making it up or if it’s real, and then you start
Shure:  你赞这
Shure: You agree with this
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure:  你来你来说一下呢
Shure: You, you say something
Shure:  哦
Shure: Oh
Shure:  你好害羞啊
Shure: You’re so shy
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure:  你有你有想到什么反例来反驳他吗
Shure: Do you have any counterexamples to refute him?
Alice: 这题选C
Alice: I choose C
其他人：这个没有选项
Others: There are no options
Lucia: 没有选项
Lucia: No options
Shure:  选C选项的同学也是非常的有个性
Shure: Those who choose C are very unique
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure:  好吧好吧
Shure: Alright, alright
Shure:  那这个问题我决定
Shure: So for this question, I decide
Shure:  二二
Shure: Two-two
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure:  二
Shure: Two
Shure:  二二
Shure: Two two
Shure:  给大家每人发两个ego币
Shure: Everyone gets two ego coins each.
Shure:  好吧
Shure: Okay
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure:  下一个问题吃止痛药打架算开挂吗
Shure: Next question, does taking painkillers to fight count as cheating?
Lucia: 这跟地球人都没关系了
Lucia: This has nothing to do with earthlings.
Alice: 这跟地球人什么关系
Alice: What does this have to do with earthlings?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 已经有同学发现了盲点
Lucia: Someone has already found the blind spot.
Alice: 是我们从弱智8找的问题
Alice: We got this question from "Weak Intelligence 8".
其他人： 上一个也是吗
Others: Was the last one too?
Alice: 是
Alice: Yes.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure:  哎呦呦哟
Shure: Oh my, oh my.
Shure:  这种大家换一个问题吧
Shure: Let's change the question, everyone.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake:没有更多了但是最后有一个问题
Jake: There's no more, but there's one last question.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure:  他的答案非常的好
Shure: His answer is really good.
Lucia: 非 相似相融
Lucia: Very similar and harmonious.
Shure:  必须再奖励一个
Shure: We must give another reward.
Shure:  你现在收获非常
Shure: You've really gained a lot now.
Shure:  颇丰
Shure: Quite a lot.
Shure:  再下一个吧
Shure: Next one, please.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure:  不孕不育会遗传
Shure: Can infertility be inherited?
Shure:  大家觉得
Shure: What do you all think?
Alice: 这是不是要被逼了
Alice: Is this going to get us in trouble?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 植物的三倍体是吧
Lucia: Is it triploidy in plants?
Shure:  二位二位学生
Shure: Two students, two students.
Shure:  来来来这个是
Shure: Come on, come on, this is...
Jake:还有一个问题
Jake: There's one more question.
Shure:  还有一个问题
Shure: There's one more question.
Shure:  那这个是什么
Shure: So what is this?
Jake:之前从0到14题之间有一个其实只有13题
Jake: Previously, between questions 0 to 14, there was actually only 13 questions.
Shure:  对刚刚有一个旗号没有
Shure: Yeah, there was a flag missing just now.
Alice:哦 对
Alice: Oh, right.
Shure:  大家有发现吗
Shure: Did everyone notice?
Shure:  这是一个彩蛋问题
Shure: This is an easter egg question.
Shure:  这个是一个5分的问题
Shure: This is a 5-point question.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure:  这是一个数
Shure: It's a number.
Shure:  对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure:  重复的就是为了迷惑你
Shure: The repetition is to confuse you.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure:  所以他遗漏了啊
Shure: So he missed it, huh?
Shure:  那重复的不算
Shure: The repeated ones don't count.
Shure:  那个遗漏了哪
Shure: Which one did he miss?
Shure:  哪个题号
Shure: Which question number?
Shure:  大家有注意到吗
Shure: Did everyone notice?
Shure:   对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure:  啊 0-13对0-13
Shure: Ah, 0-13, yes 0-13.
Shure:  他他说7
Shure: He said 7.
Shure:  9
Shure: 9.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure:  12
Shure: 12.
Shure:  这这位同学呢
Shure: What about this student?
其他人：要猜一个没有的数字 啊
Others: Guess a number that hasn't appeared yet.
Shure:  对
Shure: Yeah.
其他人：99
Others: 99.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure:  他猜过了7
Shure: He guessed 7.
Shure:  他猜过了9
Shure: He guessed 9.
Shure:  他猜过了12
Shure: He guessed 12.
Shure:  对0-13里面
Shure: Yes, within 0-13.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  13就是上一集
Shure: 13 was in the last episode.
Shure:  看来会赢
Shure: Looks like they might win.
Alice: 老师这种难题
Alice: This kind of hard question, teacher.
Alice: 我们家刘婷就不参加了
Alice: Our Liu Ting won't participate.
Shure:  猜一个吧
Shure: Just guess one.
Shure:  10
Shure: 10.
Shure:  难难道要要遗落了吗这个
Shure: Is it really going to be missed?
Shure:  这个给大家缩小一下范围
Shure: Let me narrow it down for everyone.
Shure:  在啊这个数它不是一个质数
Shure: Hey, this number isn't a prime number.
Lucia: 4
Tasha: 帮我说个3
Tasha: Help me say 3.
其他人：4
Others: 4
其他人：你拿PPT看看
Others: Check the PPT.
Shure:  继续12
Shure: Continue, 12.
小薇  : 11
Tasha: 11.
Tasha: 11
Shure:  7是质数
Shure: 7 is a prime number.
Alice: 不是质数
Shure:  5也是质数
Shure: 5 is also a prime number.
其他人：哎呀已经排除一大半了2357  11   13
Others: Wow, we've already ruled out a lot: 2, 3, 5, 7, 11, 13.
Alice: 一人猜一个
Alice: Everyone guess one.
Alice: 5是质数哈哈哈哈
Alice: 5 is a prime number, hahaha.
Shure:  5是质数
Shure: 5 is a prime number.
其他人：7年没水寨过数学了
Others: Haven't touched math in 7 years.
Shure:  请问他坚持是5那我们也没有办法
Shure: Well, if he's insisting it's 5, there's nothing we can do.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure:  你你
Shure: You, you...
其他人：我猜8
Others: I'll guess 8.
Shure:  8
Shure: 8.
Shure:  不是质数猜一个
Shure: It's not a prime, guess one.
Shure:  猜一个猜一个
Shure: Guess one, guess one.
Shure:  给个面给个面
Shure: Give me a break, give me a break.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure:  给个面
Shure: Give me a break.
Shure:  他掘得我面子
Shure: He embarrassed me.
Shure:  我的室友们他掘得我面子
Shure: My roommates, he embarrassed me.
Shure:  好吧好吧
Shure: Alright, alright.
Shure:  那翻翻呗
Shure: Let's flip it.
Shure:  我我记住了是6
Shure: I remember it's 6.
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 真的
Tasha: Really.
Alice: 没人猜啊
Alice: No one guessed it.
Shure:  啊对所以没人猜没人猜
Shure: Yeah, so no one guessed it, no one guessed it.
Alice:6我是
Alice: 6, it's me.
Shure:  所以所以我们这个大奖只能流掉
Shure: So, so this big prize just goes unclaimed.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice: 6
Alice: 6.
Jake:确实一个都没猜到99到是有人猜
Jake: Indeed, no one guessed it right, but someone guessed 99.
Shure:  那
Shure: So
Shure:  我们其实就应该到我们的Auction time了
Shure: Actually, we should be starting our auction time now.
Shure:  就是我们的拍卖时间
Shure: It's our auction time.
Shure:  那我们先有请我们的host
Shure: Let's first invite our host.
Shure:  我们的这房间的主人们
Shure: The owners of this room.
Shure:  先来拍一拍东西
Shure: To start the auction.
Shure:  来掌声
Shure: Applause, please.
Shure:  有请第一位不是我
Shure: Let's welcome the first one, not me.
Alice: 不是我还没拿
Alice: Not me, I haven't brought anything yet.
Jake:我们先统计一下
Jake: Let's tally up first.
Alice:呵呵呵
Alice: Hehehe
Lucia: 我是不是也得把我的小狗接上来
Lucia: Should I bring my little dog up too?
Alice: 你不是有那个水母灯吗
Alice: Don't you have that jellyfish lamp?
Lucia: 水母没有灯珠
Lucia: The jellyfish doesn't have a bulb.
Lucia: 它现在不是灯
Lucia: It's not a lamp now.
Lucia: 它只是 水母
Lucia: It's just a jellyfish.
Alice: 那把狗请上来
Alice: Then bring the dog up.
Lucia: 行我去请狗了
Lucia: Okay, I'll go get the dog.
Alice:这是一只娇俏的 小狗
Alice: This is a charming little dog.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Alice: 什么什么什么
Alice: What, what, what?
Shure:  来来报个数
Shure: Come on, report the numbers.
Shure:  自己手上有多少币
Shure: How many coins do you have?
Alice: 币
Alice: Coins.
Alice: 20
Alice: 20.
Shure:  那个
Shure: That...
Shure:  外外面的场记
Shure: The person outside.
Shure:  谢斌竹来谢斌竹
Shure: Xie Binzhu, come on, Xie Binzhu.
其他人：哎
Others: Hey.
Shure:  记一下账本
Shure: Note it down.
Shure:  现在大家手里的币子
Shure: The coins everyone has now.
Shure:  对你记
Shure: Yes, note it.
Shure:  因为你到时候发钱包
Shure: Because you'll distribute the wallets later.
Shure:  呃报一个姓名或者代号
Shure: Uh, report a name or code.
Shure:  小杜 小杜有15个币子
Shure: Xiao Du, Xiao Du has 15 coins.
Shure:  小杜小杜小杜
Shure: Xiao Du, Xiao Du, Xiao Du.
Alice: 小度小度
Alice: Xiao Du, Xiao Du.
Shure:  杜安迪的杜
Shure: Du Andi's Du.
Tasha: 他有15个币
Tasha: He has 15 coins.
Shure:  这位这位同学
Shure: Hey, hey, this classmate.
Shure:  11
Shure: Eleven.
Alice:呵呵
Alice: Haha.
其他人：多少个12个
Others: How many? Twelve?
Shure:  十一个还有
Shure: Eleven, and there's more.
Tasha: 那就
Tasha: So...
Alice: 你就大L吧
Alice: You should be called big L.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
其他人：XL可还地
Others: How about XL?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Tasha: 我是智性恋你懂吗
Tasha: I'm sapiosexual, you know?
Tasha: 是这样子
Tasha: It's like this.
Tasha: 我是智性恋
Tasha: I'm sapiosexual.
Tasha: 知道什么叫智性恋吗
Tasha: Do you know what sapiosexual means?
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Tasha: JK
Tasha: JK.
Tasha: JK是什么
Tasha: What's JK?
Shure:  长跑长跑
Shure: Long-distance running.
Tasha: 智性恋
Tasha: Sapiosexual.
Shure:  谢斌竹谢斌竹
Shure: Xie Binzhu, Xie Binzhu.
Shure:  记完了吗
Shure: Got it all down?
Jake:记好了记好了
Jake: Yep, all noted.
Shure:  还有一个那个男的
Shure: There's still that guy.
其他人：有两个
Others: There are two of them.
Shure:  主要老板
Shure: Mainly the boss.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure:  老板一直盯着我
Shure: The boss keeps staring at me.
Shure:  我这不好不好做事
Shure: It's hard to get things done this way.
Alice: 暗箱操作
Alice: Under-the-table operations.
Shure:  来来来你要怎么贿赂我
Shure: Come on, how are you going to bribe me?
Shure:  给你三个吧凑一下五个
Shure: I'll give you three, making it five.
Tasha: 我被笨蛋美女包围都
Tasha: I'm surrounded by beautiful idiots.
Shure:  给你凑一下5个吧
Shure: I'll make it five for you.
Shure:  好吧
Shure: Okay.
Jake:好那我们就开始
Jake: Alright, then let's start.
Tasha: 他都已经被笨蛋美女包围了
Tasha: He's already surrounded by beautiful idiots.
Shure:  好开始先对房间参观
Shure: Okay, let's start with a room tour.
Tasha: 没有没有
Tasha: No, no.
Tasha: 对身边女生不能多
Tasha: There shouldn't be too many girls around.
Jake:先先拍吧
Jake: Let's film first.
Shure:  好那就先拍吧
Shure: Okay, let's start filming first.
Shure:  把这把这一层的任务大家都做完先
Shure: Let's finish all the tasks on this level first.
Tasha: 有助于培养
Tasha: It helps to cultivate...
Shure:  好的
Shure: Okay.
Tasha: 感情
Tasha: Feelings.
Shure:  那我们进入到了激动人心的Auction time
Shure: Now we enter the exciting Auction time.
Shure:  拍卖时间
Shure: Auction time.
Tasha: 算了你身边是不是没有什么
Tasha: Forget it, do you have anything around you?
Shure:  下面有请我们的第一位拍品
Shure: Next, let's welcome our first auction item.
Shure:  不是那个哎呦他怎么断了呢
Shure: Wait, what's going on, why did it break?
Shure:  老板你干什么呢老板
Shure: Boss, what are you doing?
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes.
Tasha: 身体非常好
Tasha: Very healthy.
Lucia: 理论上说里面应该有一个灯珠
Lucia: Theoretically, there should be a bulb inside.
Lucia: 真的吗
Lucia: Really?
Lucia: 但是它没有
Lucia: But there isn't.
Shure:  好的好的
Shure: Okay, okay.
Lucia: 对而且我没有热胶枪
Lucia: Yes, and I don't have a hot glue gun.
Shure:  第一位拍卖的同学
Shure: The first student to auction.
Lucia: 这个这个角我是粘住的
Lucia: This corner is glued, but this one isn't.
Lucia: 但是这个没粘住
Lucia: But this one isn't glued.
Shure:  来介绍一下自己的拍品
Shure: Please introduce your auction item.
Shure:  就Lucia先来吧
Shure: Let's have Lucia go first.
Lucia: 我来嘛
Lucia: Me?
Lucia: 好吧稍等一下
Lucia: Alright, just a moment.
Lucia: 那我就还是用这个小狗吧
Lucia: Then I'll still use this little dog.
Lucia: 如果如果我在接下来的
Lucia: If, if in the next...
Lucia: 如果我在接下来的5分钟之内
Lucia: If in the next 5 minutes...
Lucia: 把那个水母修好了
Lucia: I fix that jellyfish...
Lucia: 我就我就再我就再来一轮
Lucia: I'll do another round.
Lucia: 就是现在
Lucia: But for now...
Lucia: 我就只能用这只小狗了
Lucia: I can only use this little dog.
Lucia: 对它是一个纸箱小狗
Lucia: Yes, it's a cardboard dog.
Lucia: 然后本来是做好
Lucia: It was originally made...
Lucia: 是为了放在我们这个房子的一楼门口
Lucia: To be placed at the entrance of our house.
Lucia: 然后左右各一个就相当于一个石狮子
Lucia: One on each side, like stone lions.
Lucia: 不过它只是一只纸狗
Lucia: But it's just a paper dog.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 然后因为因为我的水母灯
Lucia: And because my jellyfish lamp...
Alice:呵呵
Lucia: 他因为一些状况
Lucia: He had some issues
Lucia: 他没有灯珠
Lucia: He didn't have the light bulb
Lucia: 并且就是这个腿没有粘稳
Lucia: And his leg wasn't glued properly
Lucia: 所以我决定
Lucia: So I decided
Lucia: 先用这个小狗来代替它的位置
Lucia: To use this little dog to replace it for now
Lucia: 然后如果有喜欢它的朋友们
Lucia: And if anyone likes it
Lucia: 就可以尝试出一下价
Lucia: You can try to place a bid
Lucia: 好像没有什么其它可介绍的
Lucia: I guess there's nothing else to introduce
Lucia: 要不先这样
Lucia: So let's leave it at that
Shure:  呃对
Shure: Uh, right
Shure:  这个Lucia同学的这个拍品
Shure: This item from Lucia
Shure:  就是可能和我们的这个
Shure: Seems to be somewhat related to our
Shure:  ego life的主题比较相关
Shure: "ego life" theme
Shure:  就是
Shure: Like
Shure:  它是用我们这两天拆的
Shure: It's made from the boxes
Shure:  快递的一些箱子
Shure: From the deliveries we've received these past two days
Shure:  做的一些小的手工品
Shure: And it's a small handmade item
Tasha: 真的吗
Tasha: Really?
Shure:  还是比较环保比较一口的对起拍价
Shure: It's quite eco-friendly and the starting bid is just one coin
Shure:  一个一个一个币
Shure: One, one, one coin
Shure:  哪位同学
Shure: Any takers?
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay
Shure:  我们的小杜出来一个币子
Shure: Our friend Du offered one coin
Tasha: 什么东西
Tasha: What's that?
Alice: 拍卖呢
Alice: An auction
Lucia: 现在开始拍卖了
Lucia: The auction has started now
Shure:  我们的
Shure: Our
Shure:  刚才他他叫什么来着
Shure: What was his name again?
Shure:  王导是吗
Shure: Director Wang, right?
Alice: 黄儿
Alice: Huang
Shure:  啊黄导出了两个币子
Shure: Ah, Director Huang offered two coins
Shure:  还有更高的吗
Shure: Any higher bids?
Shure:  两个币子一次
Shure: Two coins once
Shure:  两个币子两次两个币子三次
Shure: Two coins twice, two coins three times
Shure:  成交
Shure: Sold
Lucia: 哪哪哪位同学来着
Lucia: Which student was it again?
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay
Shure:  现在交换你的两个
Shure: Now exchange your two
其他人：那我要记吗
Others: Should I write it down?
Jake:你要记了
Jake: You should note it down
其他人：减2个币这个币要给谁啊
Others: If we take away 2 coins, who do they go to?
Lucia: 都给我了
Lucia: They all go to me.
Shure:  Lucia现在是两个币子
Shure: Lucia now has two coins.
其他人：你现在一共多少个
Others: How many do you have in total now?
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Lucia: 两个
Lucia: Two.
Shure:  两个
Shure: Two.
Alice: 两个
Alice: Two.
Lucia: 这不刚开始吗
Lucia: We just started, right?
Shure:  那我们
Shure: Then we...
Tasha: 我卖什么
Tasha: What should I sell?
Shure:  下面有请
Shure: Next up...
Tasha: 你要买吗
Tasha: Do you want to buy it?
Shure:  第二个拍品
Shure: The second auction item.
Tasha: 我送你一个
Tasha: I'll give you one.
Tasha: 你送给你女朋友
Tasha: You can give it to your girlfriend.
Lucia: 我去我的压花还没拆
Lucia: Oh, I haven't even opened my pressed flower yet.
Tasha: 送你一个我拿出来
Tasha: I'll give you one, let me get it out.
Shure:  拍
Shure: Auction.
Katrina: 我们刚开始的时候
Katrina: When we first started...
Katrina: 我给大家每人买一束鲜花
Katrina: I bought everyone a bouquet of fresh flowers.
Katrina: 然后放花瓶里养
Katrina: Then we put them in vases.
Katrina: 然后买的是那个呃
Katrina: I bought, um...
Katrina: 白百合和呃黄的百合
Katrina: White lilies and, um, yellow lilies.
Katrina: 还有那个康乃馨和芍药
Katrina: Also carnations and peonies.
Katrina: 然后这些都是我们自己种的
Katrina: And we grew all of these ourselves.
Katrina: 然后就它慢慢开了以后
Katrina: After they slowly bloomed...
Katrina: 我们就把它放在那个压花器里面压
Katrina: We put them in the flower press.
Katrina: 然后压了两三天以后
Katrina: After pressing for two or three days...
Katrina: 晒干以后
Katrina: And drying them...
Katrina: 给大家做成这种书签
Katrina: We made these bookmarks for everyone.
Katrina: 然后就是对
Katrina: And, yeah.
Katrina: 就可以放在书里面
Katrina: You can put them in your books.
Katrina: 然后芍药的话还是挺香的
Katrina: Peonies still smell really nice.
Katrina: 然后还有这种明信片
Katrina: And we also have these postcards.
Katrina: 就是明信片的话就是会少一点
Katrina: There are fewer postcards.
Katrina: 放了几片花瓣贴在上面
Katrina: We put a few flower petals on them.
Katrina: 然后呃
Katrina: And, um...
Katrina: 就是长这个样子
Katrina: They look like this.
然后我这怎么定价呢Katrina:
Katrina: So how should I price these?
其他人：拍拍拍
Others: Clap clap clap
其他人：起拍一下
Others: Let's start the bidding
Katrina: 嗯那就是两呃两个
Katrina: Hmm, so it's two, uh, two...
Katrina: 就意义动力吧起拍
Katrina: Just the motivation for the bid
Shure:  好的
Shure: Got it
Shure:  一份明信片加
Shure: One postcard plus
Shure:  一个书签
Shure: One bookmark
Shure:  你你这个样有点多
Shure: You, you have quite a lot here
Shure:  要不我们重新定一下价呢
Shure: How about we set a new price?
Shure:  那我们就是
Shure: So we will
Shure:  四个四个来
Shure: Go with four, four
Shure:  2+2 好吧
Shure: 2+2, alright?
Lucia: 你看 撕碎之后 送在土壤里面
Lucia: See, after tearing it, place it in the soil
Shure:  两个书签加两个明信片
Shure: Two bookmarks plus two postcards
Shure:  起拍价
Shure: Starting bid
Shure:  一个ego币懂了吗
Shure: One ego coin, got it?
Shure:  两个
Shure: Two
Shure:  这个非常激激烈啊
Shure: This is really intense
Shure:  两个一次
Shure: Two, going once
Shure:  三个
Shure: Three
其他人：哦哦很多组很多组
Others: Oh, a lot of sets, a lot of sets
其他人：那没事那没事
Others: It's fine, it's fine
其他人：一个人一个不就行了
Others: One per person, right?
其他人：那没事那没事
Others: It's fine, it's fine
Shure:  落子无悔啊落子无悔
Shure: No regrets once the bid is placed
Shure:  三个一次三个两次三个三次
Shure: Three, going once, three, going twice, three, sold
Shure:  成交
Shure: Deal
Shure:  好的
Shure: Alright
Shure:  我们第一组书签加明信片
Shure: Our first set of bookmarks and postcards
Tasha: 你跟他说一个ego币一个
Tasha: Tell him, one ego coin each
Tasha: 6个打包5个ego币起卖
Tasha: Six for five ego coins, starting bid
Tasha: 算了6个
Tasha: Fine, six
其他人：哎哎哎
Others: Hey hey hey
其他人：我的钱去哪了
Others: Where did my money go?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
其他人：自己藏自己找是吧
Others: Hide it yourself and find it yourself, right?
其他人：哈哈哈哈
Others: Hahahaha
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay
Shure:  这是第一组
Shure: This is the first set
Shure:  第二组起拍
Shure: Let's start the second set
其他人：两
Others: Two
Shure:  还有两还有两组啊
Shure: There are two more groups, huh?
Shure:  两个
Shure: Two
Shure:  2个
Shure:  3个一次3个两次
Shure: Three in one go, three in two goes
Shure:  3个
Shure: Three
Shure:  还有没有加价的了
Shure: Any more bids?
Shure:  last time
Shure: Last time
Shure:  so
Shure: So
Shure:  是这么喊的吧
Shure: Is this how you call it?
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay
Shure:  还有最后一组
Shure: There's one last group
Shure:  起拍价一
Shure: Starting price is one
Shure:  一个
Shure: One
Shure:  两个
Shure: Two
Shure:  两个一次
Shure: Two once
Shure:  两个两次
Shure: Two twice
Shure:  三个一次
Shure: Three once
Shure:  可以长出
Shure: Can grow
Shure:  长出太阳花的
Shure: Sunflowers
Shure:  还有人要加价吗
Shure: Any more bids?
Shure:  听到了吗
Shure: Did you hear me?
Shure:  四个哎呦
Shure: Four, wow
Jake:啊 这么有钱啊
Jake: Wow, so rich
其他人：有钱我有150个
Others: Rich, I have 150
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure:  账本不算啊
Shure: The ledger doesn't count
其他人：我有4个
Others: I have four
Shure:  他就想想四个来吧
Shure: He's thinking of four, come on
Shure:  那4个一次 4个两次
Shure: Four once, four twice
Shure:  4个两次
Shure: Four twice
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure:  so
Shure: So
Shure:  4个三次
Shure: Four three times
其他人：笑死了
Others: Hilarious
其他人：你有吗
Others: Do you have it?
Shure:  记好账啊记好账
Shure: Keep track of the accounts, keep track
Shure:  那剩下这些就一一起出来一次
Shure: Then the rest all come out together once
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure:  还是你想留几个
Shure: Or do you want to keep some?
Tasha: 等我把我的东西卖了我替你还上债
Tasha: Let me sell my stuff and I'll pay off the debt for you.
Tasha: 爹
Tasha: Dad.
Shure:  留着OK
Shure: Keep it, OK.
Shure:  好的
Shure: Alright.
Shure:  不是币子币子币子
Shure: Not the coins, coins, coins.
Alice:呵呵呵
Alice: Hehehe.
Shure:  可以贷款
Shure: You can take a loan.
Lucia: 你不是150个吗
Lucia: Weren't you at 150?
Shure:  然后刚刚
Shure: And then just now...
Shure:  他们两位的
Shure: Both of theirs...
Shure:  还是他们两位
Shure: Or both of them...
Shure:  他们三位
Shure: The three of them...
Shure:  每人是
Shure: Each...
Shure:  减了3你减了
Shure: Minus 3, you minus...
其他人：没买没没花出去
Others: Didn't buy, didn't spend.
Shure:  还还有谁划了三个
Shure: Who else deducted three?
Shure:  他3
Shure: He, three.
其他人：我0我现在没有已经没了
Others: I have zero, I have none left.
Shure:  他
Shure: He...
其他人：他你一共多少了
Others: Him, how many do you have in total?
Shure:  黄导黄导
Shure: Director Huang, Director Huang.
Shure:  就他没变
Shure: He didn't change.
Shure:  他没变还是9
Shure: He didn't change, still nine.
其他人：我们仨都没花出去钱
Others: The three of us didn't spend any money.
Shure:  非常可惜
Shure: That's too bad.
Shure:  那个请那个场务人员不要哄抬物价啊
Shure: Please, the staff, don't inflate the prices.
Shure:  来吧下一位拍卖者
Shure: Next up, the next auctioneer.
Shure:  welcome any host animal
Shure: Welcome any host animal.
Shure:  你上吧 我来吧
Shure: You go, I'll do it.
Alice: 我来吧
Alice: I'll do it.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 我的我的CP
Lucia: My, my CP.
Lucia: 我的CP来了
Lucia: My CP is here.
Shure:  这是
Shure: This is...
Alice: Lucia的CP狗
Alice: Lucia's CP dog.
Shure:  他叫二狗
Shure: He's called Ergou.
Alice: Lucia狗的CP狗
Alice: Lucia's dog's CP dog.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 突然打人
Lucia: Suddenly hitting people.
Alice: 大家可以叫他二哈
Alice: You can call him Er Ha.
Alice: 啊其实我本来准备的是水仙种子
Alice: Ah, actually I originally prepared daffodil seeds.
Alice: 但是我P的太狠了
Alice: But I edited too much.
Alice: 我忘买了
Alice: I forgot to buy them.
Alice: 然后就做了一只纸狗
Alice: So I made a paper dog instead.
Alice: 然后这个纸狗的话赠送一个卫生纸
Alice: And this paper dog comes with a roll of toilet paper.
Alice: 捏的花已经别到他的耳朵上了
Alice: The flower I made is already pinned to its ear.
Alice: 好就这样
Alice: Alright, that's it.
Alice: 起拍价一个
Alice: Starting bid is one.
Alice: 大家不用哄抬
Alice: No need to bid too high.
Alice: 因为我还会捏
Alice: Because I can make more.
Alice: 好
Alice: Okay.
Alice: 一个起拍
Alice: Starting bid is one.
Lucia: 1个
Lucia: One.
Shure:  一个一次
Shure: One, once.
其他人：到此为止
Others: That's it.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure:  一个两次
Shure: One, twice.
Shure:  这可比Lucia多一朵花呀
Shure: This one has more flowers than Lucia's.
Shure:  那我们
Shure: So we...
其他人：2个
Others: Two.
Shure:  哎呦哎呦
Shure: Oh wow.
Shure:  两个
Shure: Two.
其他人：你哪儿来的钱
Others: Where did you get the money?
其他人： 我我我我受到蒙骗 我退了拍卖了
Others: I was deceived. I withdraw my bid.
Shure:  那就还是一个
Shure: So it's back to one then.
其他人：一个起拍价买到了
Others: Sold for the starting bid.
Shure:  so
Shure: So.
Shure:  有没有敲的这么响一点的东西
Shure: Do we have something that makes a louder sound?
Alice: 给你留着吧
Alice: Keep it for yourself.
Alice: 你多买点
Alice: Buy more.
其他人：0元购
Others: Free purchase.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
其他人：我来卖东西了
Others: I'm here to sell stuff.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
其他人：我是代购
Others: I'm a personal shopper.
其他人：
Others:
其他人：这个是我姐说的
Others: My sister said this.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
其他人：呃
Others: Uh.
其他人：想一下怎么变
Others: Think about how to change.
想一下怎么变Jake:
Other: Think about how to change it, Jake:
其他人：呃就这么说吧
Other: Uh, let's just say this.
其他人：这个东西从这个主题上来说
Other: This thing, in terms of this theme,
其他人：它是一个很环保的种子书签
Other: it's a very eco-friendly seed bookmark.
其他人：然后你们把这个东西
Other: Then, you take this thing
其他人：倒在倒在那个土壤里浇水
Other: and pour it into the soil and water it.
其他人：它就能生成种子
Other: It will generate seeds.
其他人：这是商品的实啊
Other: This is the actual product.
其他人：太阳化商品的实质价值
Other: The actual value of the product.
其他人：但是商品的附加价值就非常屌
Other: But the additional value of the product is amazing.
其他人：你们买了这个就和我姐间接的联系
Other: If you buy this, you're indirectly connected to my sister.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha!
其他人：我姐是个什么人
Other: What kind of person is my sister?
其他人：是一个
Other: She's a...
其他人：一晚上让两个男人脱房无数的人
Other: Someone who can make two men lose their homes in one night.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha!
其他人：你们只要认识了他
Other: If you know her,
其他人：人生就一帆风顺
Other: your life will be smooth sailing.
其他人：这个棋牌单直接投资掉
Other: This chess piece directly invests.
其他人：一共比棋牌
Other: It’s more than a chess piece.
Shure:  你这不行
Shure: This won't work.
Shure:  市场监督管理局提醒您
Shure: The Market Supervision Bureau reminds you.
其他人：那就那就一EGO币
Other: Then just one EGO coin.
Shure:  你这总共有几个
Shure: How many do you have in total?
Shure:  6个总共6个
Shure: Six, a total of six.
Shure:  两个一个吧
Shure: Two for one, okay?
Shure:  好吧
Shure: Alright.
Shure:  我们不希望东西它不是成对出现的
Shure: We don't want things to appear unpaired.
Shure:  对吧多孤独啊
Shure: Right? How lonely is that?
Shure:  好的那我们一ego币
Shure: Okay, then one EGO coin.
Shure:  两个种子包
Shure: Two seed packs.
Shure:  可以吗
Shure: Is that okay?
Shure:  起拍二
Shure: Starting bid, two.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha!
Shure:  两个还有更高的吗
Shure: Two, any higher offers?
Shure:  两个依次
Shure: Two, going once.
Shure:  哎呦黄导还是大气
Shure: Oh, Nicous is generous.
Shure:  三个三个一次
Shure: Three, three, going once.
Shure:  还有人要加价吗
Shure: Anyone want to bid higher?
Shure:  三个两次
Shure: Three, two times
Shure:  三个三次成交
Shure: Three, three times, sold
Shure:  好的
Shure: Okay
Shure:  第二轮拍卖
Shure: Second round of auction
Shure:  一一个起拍
Shure: Starting with one
Shure:  两个二两个一次
Shure: Two, two, once
Shure:  两个两次
Shure: Two, twice
Shure:  两个3次
Shure: Two, three times
Shure:  成交
Shure: Sold
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure:  啊还有最后一份
Shure: Ah, there's one last item
Shure:  两个一次
Shure: Two, once
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure:  还有出更高的吗
Shure: Any higher bids?
Shure:  两个两次
Shure: Two, twice
Shure:  两个
Shure: Two
Shure:  还有还有出价的吗
Shure: Any more bids?
其他人：3
Others: Three
其他人：好好
Others: Alright, alright
Shure:  好好好
Shure: Okay, okay, okay
Shure:  4个一次
Shure: Four, once
Shure:  4个两次
Shure: Four, twice
Shure:  四个三次成交
Shure: Four, three times, sold
其他人：爽了姐
Others: Satisfied, sis
Shure:  OK
Shure: OK
Shure:  我们host auction啊
Shure: We host the auction
Shure:  还有大家要拍卖物品吗
Shure: Anyone else got items to auction?
Lucia: 我现在下去做去
Lucia: I'll go do it now
Shure:  OK好的
Shure: OK, got it
Lucia: 真的我想起来我那没拆
Lucia: Really, I remembered I didn't unpack
Lucia: 大家先玩着
Lucia: You guys play first
Shure:  那现在没有了这个host auction的部分
Shure: So now, this hosting auction part is over
Shure:  然后我们现在进入到下一行
Shure: Now we move on to the next segment
Shure:  然后大家就花了很多钱
Shure: Everyone spent a lot of money
Shure:  来购入这些host的拍卖品
Shure: To buy these auction items from the host
Shure:  对吧然后所以下一个环节
Shure: Right, so the next part
Shure:  大家可以来上台
Shure: Everyone can come on stage
Shure:  简单的进行一个自我介绍
Shure: And do a simple self-introduction
Shure:  然后根据你自我介绍的
Shure: Then based on your introduction
Shure:  我们再发放一波ego币
Shure: We will distribute some ego coins
Shure:  有哪位自告奋勇的
Shure: Anyone want to volunteer?
Shure:  先上来自我介绍一下吧
Shure: Come up and introduce yourself.
Shure:  那肯定有
Shure: There definitely is.
Shure:  跟你没有关系
Shure: It has nothing to do with you.
Shure:  gas的环节
Shure: It's the gas segment.
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Yeah.
Shure:  有哪位想introduction
Shure: Anyone want to do an introduction?
Alice: 新客满三减二是吗
Alice: New customers get three for two, right?
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Shure:  那个也可以不介绍
Shure: That can also not be introduced.
Shure:  可以给大家讲个笑话
Shure: You can tell a joke.
Shure:  讲个故事
Shure: Tell a story.
Shure:  都可以就是只要你上台来我就会
Shure: Anything works, just come up and I will...
Shure:  大家
Shure: Everyone...
Shure:  评委席就会根据表现来给各位打分
Shure: The judges will score you based on your performance.
Shure:  并且发放一个币
Shure: And give out a token.
Shure:  有自告奋勇的吗
Shure: Any volunteers?
Shure:  展示才艺也可以
Shure: You can showcase your talent too.
Alice: 哈哈刘婷会唱歌
Alice: Haha, Liu Ting can sing.
其他人：你怎么不杀了钉
Others: Why don't you go first?
其他人：你先打个样
Others: You set an example first.
Shure:  我给大家当当当
Shure: I'll go first.
Shure:  我给大家自我介绍一下
Shure: Let me introduce myself.
Shure:  大家好 好
Shure: Hello everyone.
Shure:  低调低调低调低调
Shure: Keep it low-key, low-key.
Shure:  大家好 对
Shure: Hello everyone.
Shure:  我叫修硕
Shure: My name is Shure.
Shure:  呃对我来自
Shure:  然后是一位大四的文科生
Shure: And I'm a senior liberal arts student.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure:  怎么样怎么样
Shure: How was it? How was it?
Shure:  这个这个介绍还是不错的吧
Shure: This introduction was pretty good, right?
Shure:  你说好了
Shure: Alright.
Shure:  那你要上来introduction一下嘛哈哈
Shure: So, do you want to come up and introduce yourself? Haha.
Shure:  哦没有没有没有
Shure: Oh, no, no, no.
Shure:  哎呀大家活跃一点嘛
Shure: Come on, everyone, be more active.
Shure:  活跃一点对
Shure: A bit more lively, yeah.
Shure:  跟大家怎么
Shure: How about everyone...
Shure:  我又怎么了
Shure: What's wrong with me again?
Shure:  大家都是各位的亲朋好友
Shure: We're all friends and family here.
Shure:  其实也没有没有什么害羞的
Shure: There's really nothing to be shy about.
Shure:  就是想让其他的同学
Shure: We just want everyone to get to know each other.
Shure:  就是来也互相认识一下
Shure: Just come and introduce yourselves.
Shure:  毕竟一会还有顿晚餐呢
Shure: After all, we have dinner later.
Shure:  大家就是尬在那里也不好是吧
Shure: It would be awkward if everyone just stands around, right?
Shure:  没有的话我可点名了啊
Shure: If no one volunteers, I'll start calling names.
Shure:  对我现在啊开始往上
Shure: Alright, let me start from here...
Shure:  哇家暴
Shure: Wow, domestic violence joke.
Shure:  我跟你讲
Shure: Let me tell you,
Shure:  后面的拍品会还有更好的啊
Shure: There are even better items in the auction later.
Shure:  一个有没有人上来讲
Shure: Anyone want to come up and talk?
Shure:  两个了啊
Shure: That's two already.
你这个你这个家法是不会有人上去的其他人：
Other: No one will come up with your method.
完了
Other: It's over.
其他人：只会把那段全拍完
Other: They'll just finish the whole segment.
其他人：你应该是从高往低拍
Other: You should start from high and go low.
其他人：你说现实你怎么一个一往上
Other: How can you just go up and up?
其他人：大家肯定都不上去
Other: No one will come up that way.
其他人：你是不是
Other: Are you...
其他人：哈哈哈现实也不会有人上去的
Other: Haha, no one will come up in reality either.
Shure:  这一沓
Shure: This stack here,
Shure:  十个十个开始往下减
Shure: Let's start reducing by ten each time.
Shure:  来吧 40块钱
Shure: Alright, 40 bucks.
其他人：大家好啊
Other: Hello everyone,
其他人：我叫杜卓宇
Other: My name is Du Zhuoyu.
其他人：大家可以叫我小杜
Other: You can call me Little Du.
其他人：然后我就是AK刘宇轩的小弟啊
Other: I'm AK Liu Yuxuan's junior.
其他人：我就去年去年认识的
Other: We met last year.
其他人：然后我今年是在北京实习
Other: This year, I'm interning in Beijing.
其他人：然后过两天我就走了
Other: I'll be leaving in a few days.
其他人：我就去旅游一段时间
Other: I'm going on a trip for a while.
其他人：然后等到9月3去去主演
Other: Then on September 3rd, I'll be starring in something.
然后
Other: And...
其他人：我也是做做大明星相关的一些内容
Other: I'm also involved in some celebrity-related content.
Tasha: 我是AK刘雨萱的小弟
Tasha: I'm AK Liu Yuxuan's junior.